attendees are in listen only mode
muted good afternoon everyone this is
Mark Albert editorinchief of modern
machine shop magazine Welcome to our
webinar sponsored by Sanic fa America
thank you for joining us our topic this
afternoon is CNC programming Made Easy
with manual guide eye conversational
programming and this is part two
creating a basic turning
program without particular knowledge of
gcode programming it is possible to
generate part programs on the shop floor
by answering simple questions vanic
manual guide ey conversational
programming provides this capability for
Milling turning and Mill turn centers
with fanic
cnc's part one gave an overview of the
functionality of manual guide ey part
two
Builds on that introduction by reviewing
the entire progression of creating a
basic turning program with manual guide
eye today's session covers selecting
fixed forms tool selection cutting
speeds and feed rates for various
materials our presenter this afternoon
is Jody Michaels as end user account
manager for fanic fa America Jody
Michaels focus is on servicing and
supporting end users
to maximize their productivity with the
use of fanic
cnc's jod has 35 years experience in the
Machine Tool industry with various
positions in sales support Automotive
applications and training at Machine
Tool Builders and users and CNC
suppliers he is a true expert on CNC
programming and the functionality setup
and use of manual guide eye as we listen
to jod during the presentation please
please feel free to share your questions
with us by typing them in the questions
pan on your control panel Jody will
answer those questions at the end of the
presentation keep in mind this webinar
is being recorded so you'll be able to
review the entire program online later
thanks again for taking time to be with
us for the Live program here's
Jody thanks Mark good afternoon everyone
as Mark says we are doing part two of a
three-part series today and what we're
going to do today is a basic turning
program the entire sequence of events
that you have to do to create a new
program The Turning program and what
we're going to do today it's a very
simple part and it's something that we
we all would recognize it's a 2inch
trailer hitch
ball and it's got a lot of different
features that could be complicated when
you're programming it but actually man
you got makes it very easy this is just
a picture of
it and then this is an actual print of
the
part so we've got all of our dimensions
and I know none of you are going to have
time to actually make a drawing of this
but I've got one here and we'll go
through the entire process of making two
sets we'll do an A and A B set the first
side what we're going to do is the
actual ball and the relief the flans and
then on the B set what we'll do is the
left hand side where we actually turn
down the diameter and Chase the thread
on the back side and again what we're
going to do today is like what we did a
few weeks ago when we did the setup
we're going to use NC guide and actually
use the interactive manual guide eye to
actually do the programming so at this
point what I'm GNA do I'm GNA change my
screen switch programs and when actually
go into the NC guide and now to start a
new program you always want to go into
the edit mode and when we go into edit
and go left shift so this will typically
be the the screen when you first go into
the edit mode and what we want to do to
start a program you press the new
program soft key and then you give it a
number with some of our controls you'll
actually be able to give it a name but
with what the model we're using today
the zeroi model D it still wants a
number so we're going to say number
four and see it starts a new program
then typically what I do at the
beginning and again I want to emphasize
what we're showing today with the
flexibility of manual guide eye I'm
going to show you the way that I
typically do the program but you don't
have to do it exactly the same sequence
I do it once you start using using
manual guide eye you're going to come up
with your own methodology of how to make
a program and you know that's fine with
me you don't have to do it it doesn't
have to be my way but at this point
here's what I do usually I'll go into
the O list where you can edit a comment
and then I'll put a description of what
we're doing to trailer
hitch and ENT that and then when we go
back into our program see it puts a
descript ion there in parentheses so
that's how we start our program now the
next thing I typically do is go right
shift go into our start soft key and
there we have a tab to the right that's
called blank what we need to do is
Define the material that we're going to
make this part from and this is only for
simulation it doesn't have anything to
do with actually cutting the part it's
only for simulation when we get done
actually making the program and what
we're going to do is a cylinder blank
figure we select that and it'll
automatically default to whatever you
entered into these fields the last time
but I know for the part that we're
making today it's 3 in diameter so you
type in
three
input then the length is 5 in input and
then the work origin Z that's the asking
what the base of the part is and we're
going to face the end of the part like
you typically do on a la to set up a
data point at the end of the part so I'm
going to say we're gonna have a 100 THS
on the end of the part input that then
press the insert soft key it's important
whenever you're importing inputting
information into a cycle manual guide ey
that you use the input hard key to put
in information and only use the insert
soft key when you're done so if you try
to press insert actually put the the
information in the field it'll try to
input the entire thing into the program
and you won't be done and you get an
alarm so at this point we press insert
so at this point we've got two lines in
our program and it's just one is the
program number and the next one is the
actual blank and you see it gives a
description of what that gcode is down
here G9 1800 cylinder blank figure so
you can understand what that is now at
this point we have to go into our fix
form soft key and this takes us into the
fixed forms we developed in our first
part of our Series so now at this point
what we want to do at the beginning of
any program you you're gonna have start
finds where you just modal commands that
you want to make sure that are in effect
and as you can see it we have an alarm
it says imperfect word must be changed
and the reason that is in our start
lines there are certain places where I
leave question marks so that you can go
in and put in what information that you
want there because right there it's
going to start up the spindle it will
say
S100 alter you just highlight it with a
cursor type in what you want to change
it to press the alter key and it changes
it and it's asking for a feed rate now
this feed rate
you would think you wouldn't have to do
this because you're going to put a feed
rate in the cycle but if you don't put a
feed rate here occasionally if the
control does not pick up a default feed
rate when you go to run a program you'll
get an alarm saying no speed rate
commanded so that's why I always try to
put this in my start line just to keep
you from getting an alarm further down
the line so it makes it very it's very
helpful to do this at the beginning so
we'll say point 01 alter again so now we
put our start line then we go back to
our fix form we want to do a tool change
we insert that and again we get the
imperfect word must be changed and see
what I click tool with qu a t number
with question marks because I didn't
know what tool I was going to use but I
know for what we're going to create
today that we have to have a tool that
has some relief on the backside so I
know that's three tool number three
alter and then I usually put a
description
so so I know that's a 55 degree
tool spell very
well and then alter again so now and the
reason I do that is say we've run this
program a year from now we can go
through and look at the tool
descriptions and see like a tool list so
we can R tool it and then also if we put
the cursor over the entire line where
the tool number is see it gives a
description if we press the input key it
takes us into our tool
data screen and we can see tool number
three is a general
tool with a cut angle of 93 degrees and
a nose angle of 55 and that's the tool
that I want that's the tool I want to
use to ref out this this part
now the next thing that I typically put
in at the beginning of the program again
we go into fix form and it's a
positioning
move now this is something that that I
do if you read the manual guide I manual
it won't ask you to do
this but I like to do it because I like
to ensure before you go into a cycle
that I know exactly where the machine is
going to go I don't want to leave it to
the Leisure of the control itself to
decide where that is I want to go to a
known spot you know like programming 101
typically you would go 100,000 above
your stock and 100 th000 in front that's
what I always do X
3.1 then alter just like before put the
cursor over what you want to change and
then point one alter again so now we've
called up the tool we're at a we're at a
clear position but now at this
point what we want to do we want to call
up a cut speed for the material that
we're going to cut and the material
we're going to use this is
4142 preheat treated
material and most of all most all of you
are going to understand what that is and
let's see I have a selection for preheat
treated rusting cut speed we insert that
and again it says imperfect word must
must be changed and it's asking us to
give a spindle limiter so we'll say we
want to only get up to 1500
RPM and alter again so at this point
we've done all the Preparatory work to
get a tool start to spindle set up our
cut speed set up our max speed and our
feed rate so now at this point then we
can actually go into the cycle to
actually turn this part so we go to
cycle and we won't go into turning and
turning outer R is what we want to
select I want to do several of these
selections today so this is the first
one we're going to do we select that and
again as we went over in our overview in
part one it's just fill in the blanks
and if the control is going to give you
any answers there'll be a soft key down
here so it says okay which direction are
we going to go the minus that's what we
want then depth of cut this is a radial
depth of cut so for this tool we're
going to say 60,000
06 input rate of cut dep percentage
leave that at 100 defs to that then this
is the xaxis Finish amount material this
is the amount of stock it'll leave for a
finish path so I always leave 10,000 per
side and 5,000 on the shoulders
input and this is our feed rate again
01 and then this is our relief feed
rate five and then this is when it comes
out Rel 05 there also then we Arrow over
to our detail
data and it retains what we had the
first time first speed overrides 100%
cut rise method is always cut rise and
the Escape amounts are
100,000 and then the move to start the
cuts the vector move and then the third
tab is inace Machining either available
or not available and we want it
available because we want it to face the
end of the part starting in X and
feeding down to x minus so we'll say
there's a 100,000 stock on the end of
the part enter that then we press insert
because we filled out all the different
tabs all three are completely filled you
press
insert and see what it does as soon as
you fill out the Machining cycle if
there's any geometry that's to be
associated with that it'll Force you
into where you describe the geometry of
the finished part not of the rough stock
of the finished part finish profile so
for this with the part we're describing
it wants the start point and that's zero
and X zero enter zero and Z you don't
have to allow for out in front of the
park because that's within the cycle
where we told it to start 100,000s away
so it's important when you do this
geometry the trouble most people have is
they try to give it too much information
you only need to describe the finished
profile the the software is very very
astute it'll figure out where to start
from it'll figure out on it's m then me
say press the okay he key and see it
draw the start point so the first one we
have to do is we know at the end of this
part there's a flat on the end of this
ball so we need to do a line up that
first diameter and see gives you all
these different
directions for where we're describing
what we're doing and we're starting at
zero so we're going to go up and the
finished Dimension is
931000 210 so
9312 enter that now the next three
Fields typically you don't have to put
anything there the last connection and
the next connection you only put
something there as if you've got a line
that's going into meeting something on
tangent that's the only time you ever
change this the next two and then the
last one is just asking you what we are
describing the part or the blank those
are your two selections right now we're
describing the part profile so we leave
it apart and we say okay see it draws a
line and then this point it doesn't
really have any scaling because it's the
only part of the geometry we've
described so now the next thing we want
to do we have to describe the arc and
it's a counterclockwise Arc so we press
that and within this you see how all the
first five Fields all have P strings
because depending on your print you can
have a variety of different information
here so what we want to here we're GNA
tell it we know the radius is one
inch under that we know the center point
is
x0 and we know the Center Point in Z if
you draw a complete 1 in radius is minus
one
in and again nothing in the next two and
then the element type is apart again and
when we press okay you see it draws a
complete circle the blue line is the
straight line that we described then
this is the circle and the reason it
draw through a complete circle because
we didn't give it any inluence and the
control is going to f figure out where
the end points is based on what we do
next so at this point we know that
there's a
line that's going to the
left and the important in
Z
is -
2 595 and that again we don't need
anything there and we say
okay and we're going to do a
line to the
left and the end point in Z is the end
point in X is one
in and minus
2595 again you don't have to change any
those say okay see what it does you drew
this line the blue line so we knew where
the end point was and then you drew this
and if we go next it says if I draw that
line I'll cross that radius in two spots
either
there or there so we know that the one
we really want is this
one okay so we say
select see now it draws all this
correctly and the reason we've
got where the yellow is that's where
it's drawn the line now at this point we
say darn it we forgot at the end of this
radius you see up here at the top it's
showing all the different elements we're
describing at this point we know that
here I'm supposed to put a radius at the
corner of that and I gu I ignored it in
intentionally so we can go back and add
it to show you how easy that is to do so
we know there's supposed to be a quarter
inch radius at the corner there so we
put 250 enter and then say okay
and see it immediately adds the
radius and so now here we're to this
shoulder and now at this point I know in
this corner there's also a radius it's a
450,000 radius enter that then say okay
now the reason it didn't draw it yet is
because we haven't told it which way to
go yet so we're GNA do a line we're
gonna go up we're going to end up at two
and a half I'm sort of taking Liberty
with a drawing I want to make the Flames
to be a little bigger enter that again
we don't need to change any of these
last three we say okay see what it does
it drew the radius a real small flat
then another big radius up here on the
top I want another Corner radius
60,000 say
okay again it's didn't draw yet because
it doesn't know which way to go now at
this point we're going to do another
Arc and I know the end point this time
they want get
2.5
then I don't remember to go in Z but if
we press this starting point minus
incremental we press that it remembers
where we are want to go
another
five enter that so now it knows where it
is and we'll say it's
one5 1.3 radius under that then say
okay see so it draws the radius so now
we've described the entire profile of
what we want to do now the last thing
you want to do is do another line now
this one will go up now this is where
you actually describe the material that
we're cutting this
from we know it's three Ines three now
this time we go down to the last field
where it says part now we want to make
it the
blank okay the last thing you do in your
geometry is describ the size of the
material then we say okay and it'll draw
that
line okay at this point we've done all
of our geometry for the right side of
the part but now with manual guide ey
it's it's very critical that oops you
have to do it it has to be a closed
fingure so at this point if you press
the right shift key this key the right
arrow key four times one two three four
and we went through a bunch Fields there
and at some point in our next sequence
we'll go over all individually what all
those are but we don't really have time
to go through them all individually
today but now we have a soft key that
says b continuous we press
that and it brings up to give you two
selections figure one or figure
two figure one is an OD figure two of an
ID so we're doing an OD we say figure
one it says select blank his connection
yes saying are you sure that's what you
want to do
yes okay and at this point it goes back
to that screen but it gives us a soft
key that says create and that's what we
want to do at this point press the
create soft
key and we got two things we can do we
can either insert all this geometry in
our Cur
program or we can create a the sub
program you can do either
one but right now we're going to do the
first first one inserting per program
you press the okay soft
key and what it does it goes through and
adds all that to our current program now
again what we're GNA do right now my
method whenever I do a program in manual
guide eye I don't go through and program
the entire thing I like to go through
each cycle and simulate it as soon as I
get done with that cycle so at this
point just to make sure that what we're
doing is correct we're gonna go to auto
Sim
L my M simulate wasn't spelled right but
that's the way it is now rewind it'll
take us back to the start of the program
if we Press
Start you can see right
now as it's simulating see the tool it
looks like what we described it's a 55
degree tool with three degrees of lead
on the front and also see how we're
getting this message cutting residue
will occur
and what that's doing it's looking at
the angle we described on this tool and
it's saying when it once it goes in and
does the relief on the back side that
tool will not be able to get in there
and cut all of it but with this tool it
will only do what it can so here's what
we'll go ahead and start it again it'll
go ahead and finish it what it can but
you can see the geometry here is not
exactly what what we described but it
did whatever it could do with that tool
the reason we got an alarm is because we
don't have an end program yet in our
program so at this point what we need to
do is group off whenever you want to get
out simulation you press the group off
soft it takes you back to your original
screen and we go back to edit now we
know at this point we have to go in
there with a different tool to semif
finish it or finish it to get to the
right profile so now what we need to do
is just like before we go back to our
fixure
forms and we're going to do another tool
change just like we did before now this
time I know tool two is a tool that
we'll get into what we want to do so
tool two
alter and the description of that is a
degree then we alter that just like we
did before and again if we highlight the
entire line and press input
it takes us right into our tool data
selection so it's a general tool with a
35 degree tool that's what I want so at
this point what we want to do with that
tool is go to fix form and again we want
to do a turn on that pet speed again for
pre tree in the trail insert
that thenit our RPM the reason we're
doing this is where if you wanted to
only go through this tool you could go
to this this section and start only for
that tool you don't have to go through
the entire program you can start
wherever you
want so it makes it very nice for
starting the middle of the program and
alter that then again we'll do a
positioning move like we did
before positioning move insert that and
again this is something I do you don't
have to do this yourself I just like to
do it because then I know exactly where
it's starting
from I like to have a little bit of
control for that one aler that so at
this point we've done tool change we
called up our cut speed so now what we
want to do is go back to
cycle turning and now this time we could
either do semif finish or finish either
one so we're going do two finish and
we'll select that and again the Finish
cycle is much simpler there's not very
much to fill out for Z
minus and a feed rate we'll slide down
enter that then insert that and again
see it takes us into where it wants us
to describe the Finish profile again but
we don't want to go through all that
hassle of drawing that again so we'll
say cancel Cancel and now what we're
going to do we're going up and
copy where we described it the first
time so we go 1450 will always be the
beginning of
it
and at this point we're sort
of uh we're sort of locked up at this
point but let me see if I
can set it off and start it back up and
get back out of sorry about
that back
into sometimes go
a
loop yeah see it's sort of locked up in
a loop and I apologize for that let me
just exit out of those and let me start
it back
out
this will get us right back to where we
were no
problem again what we're going to do now
we're going to copy the
geometry of what we were working on
before guess we'll just bring this right
back into NC
kind and it well saved while we were
where we were
before see it's just booting up again
and it looks a good thing about NC Guy
this is a good way of showing how it
starts it looks exactly like
the original control and we go to edit
and we're right back to where we were
all I'm going to do is go down here as I
said I want to copy from this point I
want to
copy to let me do
that
okay try this one more time
one more time and I apologize for the
delay here but we'll get back here and
TR in a
second it'll do it up again I'll do it
differently this
time boting up to control again again
like said didn't
guided the good thing about it for
training it's very invaluable because it
shows the control exactly like what you
would
use I'll turn that
off
edit I'm on page
down this
time it shows the
profile and I'm going to
copy I'm going Arrow it all the way down
to
1456 just the last line we'll say
copy then we just page down to where we
did the finished profile and then we
just paste it back in see now all we did
was just went in and copied the profile
from the rough we didn't have to redraw
it we then went have to make mistakes so
now we go to auto we're going to siml
we're going to start it again see now
now it goes through and roughs it with a
55 now it goes in with a 35 see now it
looks like the actual profile what we
want so at this point we've roughed it
we finished it so now the right end of
the part is actually done so now at this
point like I said we go back to group
off but we know at this point we go back
to edit
and we page all the way down now at this
point what we want to do is we go back
to our fix forms just like
before it's going just like
before it's not going to cooperate with
me today but that's
okay it's a test it's just a test to
show you how easy it is to get in and
out
of obviously it wouldn't do this to you
on your computer control this is mainly
it has to do with my
computer and again I apologize but U
we'll get right back into and what we're
going to do next is we're going to put a
program stomp in the middle of our
program because we've concluded the a
set of our
program typically with a part where you
can't do the entire thing from one side
you'll have an A and A B set so now
we're going to do the other side the B
set okay we'll reset that
edit we're going to page all the way
down to here we're going to go to a fix
form and what we're going to do is our
program
stop let's see where it is see we got
program stop Turn part around insert
that that'll let you know when you get
to that spot you have to turn the part
around and then we're going to do a fix
form we're going to do a tool change I
know for this one it's tool
one11 alter and I know for this one it's
an 80° tool because what we're doing on
the backside there's no
release where we have to do use a tool
with release l so we can use an 80
degree tool it's stronger we can take a
bigger
deput and then alter
that so we've called that tool up and we
got a fix form we want to do our cut
speed our preheat C speed and again we
limit it that's
1500 alter
that and we want to do a position move
just like I told you what I always like
to do is a positioning move to know
where I'm going we insert that again in
perfect word must be changed X 3.1 but
we're still using the same material
alter that and Z 0.1 alter that at this
point we need to go go in and describe
our blank again so it'll draw a new one
for the back side select that it retains
what we had before we still want to use
that insert that so at this point we're
ready to go in and do our cycle so we do
cycle and turning now this time we're
going to
do outer rough and finish from the same
tool we can use the same tool this time
so again Z minus our cut Direction .1 is
our Deb cut finish stock
015 on this side
05 on there our feed rate is
01 0 Z five on our other
two then now this time it that's for a
finish feed rate
04 and it defaults it retains what we
have on our detail then we wa say
available for the face DM point1
enter and then
insert again now we have to go describe
our profile now with this this time we
go in we're gonna start at zero again
zero and z and say okay and then we'll
do a line and our diameter going up is
one
inch one inch we don't have to put
anything on the next three just like
before
but we do want to put a corner chamfer
because we're going to chase threads on
this side so has
0125 and a inch wide Cher it'll be 45
degrees again it didn't draw yet because
of it doesn't know which direction to go
yet we say line to the
left and we'll say minus one.
575 okay again we don't have to do
anything for those and say okay it draws
the
line with the chamfer here and we want
to do a line up up to two and a
half that's where we ended up on the
other side say okay that draws that we
want to put another Corner radius there
60,000 say okay it didn't draw that yet
because we didn't know tell where to go
yet the line to the
left and if we press the start Point
minus incremental we press that it
remembers where we were we won't go
another 100,000 so like one does the
math for you and again this is still
part part okay so it draws a small
yellow line here now the last thing we
want to do is we want to go up to our
stock size 3
in and again but now this time it's the
blank again the
blank all right so that's very simple
the last sign is the actual blank sign
and we say okay it draws that so at this
point if you remember what we did on the
other side we have to close that figure
again it's right shift four times one
two three four The
Continuous number one is a OD number two
would be an ID so still number one you
say yes we want to select that so we
want to
create now this time we're going to
create a sub routine the
subprogram just to show you what it does
when you do that and we're gonna say
five 22 is
our and
thread we're going to describe it we say
okay see what it does instead of in
inserting all those lines Within the
program it just puts one line and it
tells you what an m98 is that calls the
subprogram number
522 so at this point we've done all the
geometry for the back side so we go into
Auto Sim
laap
rewind and
start and it does all the the first
end goes all the relief it goes in with
a 35 and finishes that now does the
other side it turns it all
down so now we've done all that so now
what we need to do turn group off
because now we got to add a thread to I
want show you how easy that is to do
thread today it's definitely FY here it
doesn't like me much
today that's all right we'll get back
out of it start it back out again I
apologize for this
it's got something to do with my
computer but now what we need to do next
is add a thread tool then do a thread
it's just two lines of code very
simple very simple so we go back into
horizontal T it brings in the guide back
out just like the
to all we need to do at the end of the
program as I said is just add our
threading tool with I know is tool
number two tool number
10 and so we go into our fixed
forms and we're going to do a tool
change and it's like I said it's tool
10 alter
that we go over here and say that's a
thread that now this time our fix form
we only want to start SP you don't want
to use
cut constant surface speed when you're
doing the thread and it starts at at 500
we're all right with that and we do a
fix form to do a positioning
move insert that again it's X 3.1 3.1
alter 3.1
alter then we just go into
cycle
treading treading outer or inner we want
outer it's very simple just fill in the
planks single depth anything with an ASC
you don't have to answer that to finish
them out we could leave more finish
stock for the last half this is the
number of finishing passes cut depth and
we're gonna save 01 for depth cut and
the details just the approach moves and
we insert that we want to do a unified
thread because it's a standard inch
thread we select that and again it says
fill in the blank the thread diameter is
1 inch the start point is zero it'll
start out in front on its own and we
want an eight threads per inch the
length is
[Music]
1.125 the depth it we do the
calculations for you for the
depth and that's all you need to do you
press insert it puts it in the program
so we know we're done now with the
program that's everything so we put an
end
program insert that so it's totally
finished the program but now we want to
simulate the whole thing we go to auto
Sim laap
rewind and
start so it goes in simulates the entire
time finish turns it does the other end
it chases the threat no problem so at
that
point then you could actually go if you
turn group off it takes you back to this
screen you could we could rewind it from
there you could actually put a part in
this the Chuck press cycle start it
would actually go in and run the
part all right but of course we don't
want to do that at this point because
we're done what we want to do right now
something I want to show and we're
almost finished here but okay you've run
apart using the conversational now at
this point you say now I want to convert
it to a gcode program it's very simple
to do that at this point we're in Auto
or memory or whatever your control might
say if you press the right shift key you
have a soft key that says NC convert you
press that it says okay give me a
different number
five okay so now it's got a split screen
if we Press
Start see it's going through and reading
the program on the right hand side and
creating a G-Code program on the left
side and they're all just straight Point
too
moves and turning in drilling it'll use
drill drill can cycles and in threading
it'll use a can cycle like a g78 or a
g92 but right now it's actually creating
a real G-Code program on the leftest
side
something you could take from this
control or your machine that you're
using take it out of that and put it in
another machine with a saning controll
it doesn't have manual guide eye you
could use it gcode is G-Code you could
use it wherever you'd
want so it's very powerful that way now
it'll take a few seconds for it to make
the gcode program I'll let it
finish then the last thing I want to
show you before we go into our questions
there's also a way where it will do a
Time study too where say you're a small
shop and you want to figure out how long
it would take to make the part it will
do a time conversion too based on
whatever your cut speed and everything
on so if we press the return and at this
point if we go to
edit okay you go right
shift okay I need go one back where it
says Sim lab you get a sim
left then right shift again and we'll
get to where we have a key that says
insert time okay we press insert and it
says machine time data in is inserted
okay yes let's see what it did up here
where it says time 755 A14 what that
is the actual cut time is 12 minutes and
35 seconds and the non-cut time is 14
second the reason that's so low is
because in this simulator it does not
actually have feedback from the spend so
that's why but with a real machine it
would have real values
there so at this point that's all I
really wanted to show today I think
we've went through the entire process
going through and the entire program so
what I want to do here now
is this and we go right back into where
we were I'll turn back to Mark where go
through any questions we might
have okay thanks Jody um that that was
really interesting um I guess having sat
through part one part two you know it
just uh had a lot more to offer here I
yeah we do have some questions so we're
going to jump into those
um one of the questions is about cutting
threads other than
30° and then parenes the yeah buttress
or
Acme can you help us to answer that one
sure sure because I think you noticed
when we went when we did the threading
cycle on this particular part you know
it gave you several different choices
about describing the thread itself and
within the general thread data it's the
most powerful because with it you can
give it an X and A Z start point and an
point so you can
do thread angle threads that aren't
typical papered threads and plus you can
describe in your tool data the different
angles of what the tool might be because
you know like the an acne thread it's
going to be like a a 14 and a half
degree you know it's 29 degrees it's a
total angle on the tool itself so you
can describe that and then the the the
control itself the software will Pi up
that angle the way it in feeds into the
thread itself so you sort of got to play
with it now with a betus thread unless
of my experience that I've had with
those is
typically like the backside angle is
actually in the insert
itself and so you can set up the front
side to be the correct angle for the Met
thread and then it'll actually form the
back side of it based on the insert
itself Mark that's how it does
that okay good okay another question
from our attendees is um how about
leftand
threads oh yeah that's no problem well
you you can tell it to go either way
depending on the tool I'll say typically
on a slant bed if you're going to chase
threads towards the spindle towards the
Chuck you'd have to have an upside down
tool but if you have a tool that's right
side up and go towards the chunck it'll
make your left hand thre
so there's a lot of different ways you
can do it different people you know if
they're going to use the same one or a
leftand thread the same tool they'll
start to the inside and
come towards the tail stock on the
machine yes it'll it'll do leftand
threads no problem you can tell start
wherever you want so that's no
problem okay
um question here when uh doing profile
of aart would your line moves be
opposite versus front or back
turret no it would it would still be the
same it would still be the same it's you
just the way I've got you know the
software I did today was based on the
turret being on the top but you still it
just swings it all the way around it
just it would still it would still be
the same it would still be the
same okay all right um JY how about
another question here is um from a user
how do you cut and paste in manual guide
eye well and that's that's very
simple the easiest way for me to show
that is it's actually shut in manual
GUI if we go back into it I'm we're in a
program and we're an
edit let me turn the group off that's
actually cut and
paste if we get to the the first edit
screen you know you got copy cut and
paste top Keys here if you go
copy and we just arrow down copy and it
asks you to select a range then you just
page down and you can see what I'm
highlighting and copy that and then you
just page down or wherever you want to
put it I'll put it at B the bottom of
the program and just press paste it's
that easy it's just like the word
processor it's very simple very
simple okay good good um another
question here Jody from our attendees um
how about importing fixed
forms yes for that this is you know
people ask this all the time but you got
to get to the right screen to do it
you're you have to be an edit you go
right
shift until you get to a setting self
key the self key you press that and you
pick whichever one you want to do your
register fix form sends
for then you have an input soft key so
you press that and like right now mine
is set up to where I'm looking at a
memory card if we page down through
what's on my memory card I have a file
that's called Fix
for. that's the fix forms and you just
say input and it inputs them into the
the control itself in the Manu right on
and what's good about it is the fix
form file you can open that up on your
desktop or your laptop because it's only
a text file you could actually edit them
offline and then put them back in
machine they're very they're very easy
to
manipulate
okay all right Jody one more question
here um how about changing parameters in
manual gu eye yes you can do that also
and typically you know you just go into
system and here it takes you right into
your parameters now typically the the
parameters for manual guide
ey they're up in the the very very high
parameter ranges and that's one thing
that I wanted to make sure I emphasize
today is some of the things that I
showed you today on my name that ey
might not necessarily be turned on on
your version of it so there might be
things that you might need to send us an
email and they're they're all there
they're just not turned on so that's one
GL somebody ask question because there
are certain things that that you need to
turn on different Builders will turn
have a different parameter content for
manual
GUI sometimes it's not the most optim
optimized version of
okay all right
um again we have we have a little bit
more time for some few more questions so
uh if anyone wants to submit a question
by typing them into the question pane on
the control panel uh we're going to try
to get to those and if we don't get to
the question while we're on the air um
we'll get to them later I want to remind
everybody the webinar is being recorded
and uh you know so we'll get a chance to
uh uh go through it when it's online
here
um how about the this question how do I
go about getting the PC
simulator that the PC simulator
okay okay you'd have to contact you know
your either your dealer or your local
fanic representative and uh it's it's an
inside NC guide and there's three
different versions of it Mark there's
you know the academic
version which is uh fairly
inexpensive and it's mainly used for
training you can do
programming and training look at
parameters and everything on the the
academic version but you can't take the
programs you create out and put into
something
else and then there's a version just NC
guide the middle version and with it you
got the full capability of doing just
like you did before but you can take the
programs from it and put into a machine
and actually run them you can make a
gcode program you can import gcode
programs from a cam system into it
simulate those so it's a very powerful
when you have NC guide Pro which is a
version where you can import the ladder
all the parameters you can set up your
offline version to look exactly like the
machine that you have it in out on your
shop floor so you have three different
persons but you need to contact except
either your local dealer where you
bought the machine or your local Sanic
representative okay great okay I've got
another question here and and this might
be the last question we have time for
but uh question is can uh you adjust the
taper of a thread in manual guide
eye
sure sure yes and and the the way you do
that Mark Mark is uh let me go into the
side here if we go into the figure of
threads the EAS way that is actually
because if you do a an OD pipe thread
it's going to use a 3/4 paper per foot
paper that's just a standard pipe thread
if you go into General thread if you
select that with it it asks you for a
start point in X and a start point in Z
so you can make it any angle you want
because you know a lot of a lot of
downhole pipe threads are some crazy
angles it's not 3/4 T per fo so this is
where you would actually set that up
within this General type threading
cycle you can make whatever angle you
want whatever you can imagine
make all right uh Judy let me squeeze
one more question in here um it says my
tool description selection for the
thread tool appears to only have a 60°
is this a parameter
issue I'm
not see when you go
into
down
here put
29 you know it'll let you
put you know whatever angle you'd want
to put there
so you're not limited it might be I
don't think it's a parameter Mark
okay
just yeah here's a another question um I
think this is a good one can you write a
program while the machine is
running yes yeah it it does have
background in it yeah when you're an
edit there is a background
edit but now
it's the control is entirely capable of
doing it but
frankly I whenever I do training I
usually recommend to people that they
don't do that because you know anytime
you got several different things going
on and you're watching the machine run
and you're trying to program at the same
time the M the machine will do it the
control will do it yes that is the
answer I don't recommend it but it is it
will do
it okay that's that's yeah that that's
good advice Jody okay uh I think we got
to all the questions so um I want to
thank Jody again for presenting his
slides and answering the questions um
for those attending this afternoon
session uh you can contact fanic fa
America if you'd like more
information and um we're going to get
that contact information on the screen
yeah here we go yeah okay uh
um again you know I if you missed part
one of this three-part series you can
find it on our website MMS online under
the webinars tab and part three will be
held on Wednesday March 13th and we'll
focus on creating a basic mailing
program so everyone who registered for
today's webinar will receive an an email
getting them to sign up for part three
or you can go to fanic website homepage
to register in that that website is ww.
ffa.com
and so uh we really appreciate the time
everybody's taken to be with us thisno
and hope you found it worthwhile thanks
for taking part and my thanks also to
those who arranged this session helped
It Go real smoothly so this concludes
our webinar have a great day everybody
this is Mark Albert at modern machine
shop magazine signing
off